gernot hassknecht analysiert den müden
deutschen wahlkampf in 132 sekunden
deutschland 2017 ein land ist friedlich
eingeschlafen gut im februar den sich
mal fünf leute kurz für politik
interessiert aber das konnte im keim
erstickt werden und so regierte ewige
hosenanzug in tausendsten jahr seiner
regentschaft unverwüstlich vor sich hin
wie so ein buddha weitgehend unbehelligt
von den leuten die wir älteren früher
journalistin andern hier
diese szene fast das ganze elend
zusammen
der herausgeber vom handelsblatt ist
sich vor nix fies vielen dank frau
merkel wie viel da wird dieser haben sie
einmal umarmen wie reimer
[Applaus]
nun ist schwänzen wo man hinkommt beim
unsäglichen tv-duell ja auch da wollten
diesen da mal ne etwas lockere sendung
machen mit publikum und nach harten und
merkel so super idee und die sender dann
so ja gut dann nicht ich kann nicht für
die ard sprechen und auch nicht für
diese beiden bierdosen kanäle da aber
warum aber mainz hätte es nicht einfach
gesagt alles klar
dann machen wir es eben ohne dich dann
tritt schulz hat nichts gegen dich an
sondern gegen diesen golden retriever
das wäre auch nicht langweiliger und du
kannst dir das duell einem schwarz
weißen in der oper während du deinen
hätten als teil des sensors hentrich ja
weißt du was ich glaube
jever haben nichts gemein
[Applaus]